this is from the mirrors so this is a
story that's been sent to me I don't
know
about 600 times maybe in the past in the
past couple of days I'm not complaining
by the way for good reason
um
so the mirror reports a group of
Peruvian villagers are living in fear
as uh they believe they're under attack
by mysterious seven foot tall aliens
that they've named Los palakaras which
translates to the face peelers in a
remote District of Alto nane nane I
don't know an A and A Y on a
uh located Northeast of Lima members of
the ikitu tribe hailing from the San
Antonio native Community have recounted
chilling encounters with these
extraterrestrial beings descriptions of
the alleged extraterrestrial beings
include uh large heads yellowish eyes
and Immunity to the villagers hunting
weapons
some villagers have likened the aliens
to the mythical pelicaras from folklore
creature said to Feast on human faces
fat and organs
villagers claim that these animatic
figures often shrouded in dark colored
hoods have been targeting their
Community for nearly a month since July
11th multiple incidents have been
reported with the most recent evolving a
15 year old girl it was hospitalized
after confrontation with the aliens
um there have been other and I've as I
said I've read
this is not just the mirror that you
might say well this is the mirror what
is that
what kind of publication is that that's
not credible well I'll have you know
that this uh that this invasion of the
face peelers has been reported by
um many media outlets and in some of the
reports what they're saying is that
actually these aliens look a lot like
the Green Goblin from Spider-Man
um
so
that's the story now
I have also seen videos that are um
gonna that purport to show
well I don't know what they're supposed
to show I've seen videos where lots of
things are happening
in the videos and it appears that
there's disturbing things happening but
you can't really see the aliens
but by no means should that should that
dissuade us from believing this
look these uh these face peelers
they're hiding in the woods they're not
just going to come out when you pull
your phone out this is one of the one of
the ridiculous one of the many
ridiculous points that Ben Shapiro
brought up in our debate where I
destroyed him he said well why is why
aren't the aliens on on uh on video
you think it's that simple you think you
just pull your phone out and the aliens
is going to say you think the face
peeling alien is going to say okay here
you go let me pause let's take a selfie
before I eat your face is that what the
alien's gonna say let's be realistic
about this so it's not that simple
I don't want to hear that I've heard too
much of this that the Skeptics
that don't believe these people is it
Skeptics online well I wanted to see
video I need to see video
oh do you wanna you wanna go down to
Peru
with your uh with your camera phone and
and try to get try to get the face
peelers on video you want to do that
one of the face peeling aliens comes up
to to you is that what you're gonna do
you're gonna pull your phone out right
away so you can get it on social media
so you can get it on Twitter for your
Twitter likes huh
no what you're gonna do is you're gonna
run away from the face peelers so that's
why they're not on video
in fact the fact that they're not on
video is all the more proof that they're
real think of it that way
so I believe them
um I believe them and I think that
frankly if you doubt this story that uh
not only are you denying the evidence
and you're denying the science but even
and I don't use terms like this very
often I don't throw this kind of charge
around very often but I would even say
that it's culturally insensitive and
frankly You could argue racist uh to not
believe these proven villagers who are
speaking their truth and talking about
their experiences with the face peelers
and I believe them and uh so the aliens
are here
and they're peeling faces down in Peru
and soon they'll be here
okay
and you know why do they want to peel
faces I don't know
the aliens have in common that came a
long way they've been doing their
research they've been on tick tock
they've seen what people look like these
days
they've seen a lot of faces
and they said we gotta peel those faces
off that's gross
we can't invade Earth with people
looking like that so it could be that
could be that I don't know I don't know
the motivation
anyway it's real it's happening okay
well speaking of uh the face peelers you
know uh well let me start with a brief
story of
um
Hope and Dreams I was told a couple
weeks ago I think I mentioned on the
show in fact it was mechanic texted me
and said that uh paint your life a
wonderful sponsor wants to come back on
the show and is there any painting that
I would like for them to do for me
um so that I can talk you know more
authentically about my experience of
paying your life and they've done
paintings for us in the past that were
great
and uh I was asked well is there a
picture of your kids or a vacation with
your family that you would like
memorialize in a painting and I said no
we have enough of that like I know what
my kids look like it's it's we don't
need any more pictures of it what I said
is I would like something
that maybe doesn't memorialize an event
that is technically really happened or
maybe it does
but instead it it speaks to a deeper
truth and so I ask can I get a painting
of me
greeting our alien overlords when they
land on Earth will you paint that for me
paint your life
and well this was their answer let's
unveil
for everyone to see Sean is here thank
you Sean
and there it is can we see that on
camera
is the painting uh there I just want to
say
you know
I don't get emotional very often on the
show I try not to to get emotional and
I'm holding back my emotions now but as
much as I can but when I lay my eyes on
this I see such beauty such raw Beauty
and truth that uh it does it makes me it
makes me well up with I mean it almost
brings a tear to my eye almost
um and there are so many details of this
you know I just had this Vision in my in
my head but I didn't have it fully
formed and so
they were able to take that vision and
even include details that I never
expected I mean we've got the wall we've
got the product placement in in the
which I think I think it makes it even
classier so this is already a very
classy painting but having the product
placement in the painting as well
is so much classier so we've got our
merchandise we've actually have and I
don't know how do you explain this did I
greet the aliens with merchandise from
the Matt Walsh store on dailywire.com is
this a gift that I gave them when they
landed did they already have it
themselves did they land because they're
big fans of the Matt wall show did they
come all this way to have me sign the
merchandise these are all that's a still
you know that's what's so wonderful
about this piece of art this Masterwork
this masterpiece is that that's a story
you can
um decide for yourself you know
and I think that through the ages when
people look upon this painting that will
one day be in the Smithsonian
um they will they'll debate this you
know they'll say did this happen did it
not really happen did it happen only in
spirit
um
but before it makes it to Smithsonian uh
at least for the rest of my lifetime
this painting will be hanging
in our living room
uh above the fireplace I did tell them I
said make the painting as big as you
possibly can
and they made it even bigger than I
thought
and so uh
I'll be bringing this home to my wife
and I and I you know based on my
experience with this sort of thing
if I know my wife and I think I do she
is going to love this she's going to
look at that and say can we get five of
them made
can we get a painting like this in every
room of the house
that's what she'll be mad about she'll
say oh
Matt you only had you only did one of
these
well that's that's as far the living
room but what are we gonna have in our
bedroom for example so anyway I'm very
much looking forward to bringing this
home and for the way
how how it will help to also strengthen
my marriage as well so this is great
thank you to Penelope go to
paintlife.com and get your own I don't
even know if they'll make a painting
like this for everybody but uh they made
one for me so great okay
uh we'll just keep that in the
background as we move on to some of
these comments here I don't know how we
can move on from that I almost feel like
there's no point but
um
all right this is from
if you want to go you can Sean is just
standing off in the he's like lingering
because I don't think he doesn't want he
doesn't want to make noise but
I just can't can someone glaring at me
while I'm reading these comments okay
anyway
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there